there was one time where she was
straddling him like this
beating him in the face with her titties
just
i don't think you're getting the right
visual okay uh
guys this isn't five foot two 110 pound
titties
this is six foot
250
just
[Music]
that's how big our titties were they
made that noise through the air
it was like being hit with a tint
missile just
[Music]
dude had a swollen eye from titty
punches you've never seen that in the
history of [ __ ] never ever i'll tell
you that right
now so she
thinks her job is done right she walks
over here to this side of the room
my buddy gets up mad
you know when you can tell someone is
mad where they never take their eyes off
of that thing they're mad at so he gets
up and he walks away from her like this
[Music]
and then something in him just snapped
and he just looks at her and he goes
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
and like a wave of calm crashed over her
like serious like bruce lee entered the
dragon com she was just like
[Applause]
and they ran at each other
guys you understand what's happening
they're [ __ ] fighting for real now
it's the best gift i've ever given to
myself ever are you kidding me they're
running at each other i'm like i don't
even know how this is going to end oh my
god
they're running at each other and my
buddy was mad and he screamed i want to
take you down
running at each other full speed and he
ran into her i'm gonna tell you
something he really did try to take her
down i'll tell you what he did not
just
[Music]
titties just
[Music]
titties
[Music]